students remember okay just a basic as
when they're graphing sign they think
okay it starts at zero and then it goes
to the max zero min0 max0 min zero max
so basically the zeros are alternating
with the maxes in the mins okay but with
cosine cosine starts at the maximum goes
to zero
minimum zero max so if you can kind of
remember they have the same shape but
sine is starting at this midline
whereas cosine is starting at the
maximum okay so you're with me so far so
let's get into these more challenging
examples now so example one okay you can
see that this is in this form y equals a
sine B X minus H plus K but one thing
you want to notice is you want just one
X okay here inside of these parentheses
but see how there's that one half there
so we're gonna want to do is we're gonna
factor out that one half so if i factor
it out and this is where sometimes
students make a little bit of a little
bit of a simple error what do you think
this value is gonna be right here any
ideas what do you think well this is
going to be two pi now how do I know
it's two pi well if I distribute the 1/2
times two pi see how I get back pi so
what you're doing is you're factoring
out one half but you actually have to do
the reciprocal action have to multiply
this by two but you can double check
your work if you distribute you can see
you're getting this original quantity
back okay so now what we want to do is
we want to analyze what is the period
and you can use this formula period
equals two pi divided by B this B value
and that works for sine and cosine 2 pi
is the normal period remember once
around the unit circle 2 pi but in this
case see how it's 1/2 so what's 2 pi
divided by 1/2 well that's going to be 4
pi okay because when you divide by 1/2
it's like multiplying by the reciprocal
it's multiplied by 2 so that's 4 pi now
what I like to do from here is I like to
you know draw my graph but now that I
know my period is 4 PI I like to divide
this into four pieces and make my scale
pi so in this case I'm just going to
count by PI so this is 1 pi 2 pi 3 PI 4
PI 5 PI and so on you can go here to the
left negative pi negative 2 pi and so on
and then over here let's see this is 1/2
negative
one negative two negative three now you
can see in this basic R after H and K
that's our ship that's what's gonna pick
up the graph shift it left and right up
and down but remember the one that's
grouped with the X actually has the
opposite effect so if this was like
minus PI you would actually going
positive PI to the right if it's plus PI
then you're gonna go to the left so here
we have plus two pi that means we're
actually gonna go left two pi the minus
three means we're gonna go down three so
let me change my graph a little bit to
make sure we have enough room here so
one two three
can i condense it down a little bit and
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna draw on
this midline
like this and at negative two PI I'm
gonna drawn like a accidents like that
so what I'm doing is I'm thinking about
instead of graphing from here like we
normally do let's think about graphing
from right here okay so what we've done
is we've taken it into account that
shift we've taken into account the
period which is four pi we're dividing
up to four pieces just like the four
quadrants over here and then now all we
have to do is look at this negative two
now what do you think the negative does
to the graph well if you were to put a
negative in front of this sign it's
gonna make all the Y values the opposite
if they're positive gonna become
negative they're negative they're to be
positive so it reflects it over the
x-axis and then the two is the amplitude
that's gonna stretch it vertically so
what we're gonna do here is normally
sine would look like this we're gonna
reflect it so it's going to go instead
of going up it's gonna go down like that
and it's gonna stretch it so let's see
so this is going to put us at sine
starts at the midline so we're going to
start right here then we're going to go
down to negative two we're gonna go back
to the midline we're gonna go up to okay
from from the midline so that's gonna
put us right here and then we're gonna
go back to the midline and it's gonna
repeat now how did I know you know to
graph like like I did just like the Hat
well remember when I took the period for
pi and I divided by four so each step I
was just going one pie on my X direction
and then I just had to calculate you
know my amplitude was two so I was going
you know down two or up two from that
midline so that was a good example we're
gonna do a cosine graph next but before
I get into that I just wanted to mention
that if you're preparing for that a CT
or the SAT the math sections check out
my to video courses I've got one for the
AC
it goes through 65 concepts 1 for the
SAT goes through 39 concepts and we go
through a teaching section we go through
formulas we go through example problems
and a lot of students have already taken
these video courses and have reported
back this helped them improve their
scores so I'm sure it'll help you too
but what you can do is go over there
check out the three free lessons for
each of the two courses you'll get some
benefit from those definitely to help
you raise your score right away and if
you're interested then you can go on and
purchase the course and take the other
lessons if you're interested in private
tutoring you can also contact me about
that for a CT SAT or just for your math
class I'm available for for online
tutoring but let's go through this last
example now so you can see here we've
got a cosine graph the amplitude is 1/2
the vertical shifts up two we've got a
little bit of a mess here ok what we
want is we just want it to look like
this where there's one X inside of the
parenthesis so we're gonna actually
factor out that 4 now again don't make
that a simple mistake that some students
make of factoring out the 4 out of this
term but not this term so you want to
factor that out so this is actually
going to make this let's see X minus PI
over 8 now again you can check your work
if you distribute the 4 you're gonna get
back to PI over 2 so you know you're on
the right track okay so now hmm let's
take a look at our graph so we know that
the B value is 4 and if we use our
formula period equals 2 pi divided by B
we're getting a period of PI over 2 now
again you can multiply that by 1/4 or
divide it by 4 but we're going to use
for our scale is PI over 8 okay so our
scale like how we did over there so what
I'm gonna do now is I'm just going to
graph this so I'm gonna say 1 PI over 8
2 PI over 8 which is PI over 4 3 PI over
8 4 PI over 8 which is PI over 2 5 PI
over 8 6 PI over 8 which is 3 PI over 4
and so on and we can go this direction
as well so negative PI over 8 negative
PI over 4 which is 2 PI over 8 and so on
and then let's see over here we're gonna
make this 1 and we're gonna make this
negative 1 okay let's see here so let's
make this a little bit let's make this
like maybe one right here and we'll make
this 2 right here ok so now what we're
going to do is
gonna take the shift into account so the
plus two means is shifting the graph up
to so I'm gonna draw in like this this
mid line right here okay that's gonna be
like our x-axis the minus PI rate is
going to shift it right pi every so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to draw on
kind of like our new y-axis we're gonna
think of this as our starting point or
our new origin okay instead of graphing
from here we're gonna graph from here
the amplitude is 1/2
it's a cosine graph so remember cosine
starts at the maximum so I'm gonna start
right up here let's say this is 3 up
here I'm going to start at 1/2 so it's
gonna be right there okay and then it's
going to go down to the midline that's 0
down to negative 1/2 back to 0
that's the midline back to positive 1/2
this is a little bit further over right
about there so that's it so a quick and
easy way to do this again it's just to
go through the same steps like we did
here think of that shifted origin and
graph from that point draw in those mid
lines and also draw in that new y-axis
that'll give you a little bit of better
idea about how to graph these more
challenging sine and cosine graphs so I
hope this helped you understand a lot
better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
math videos I'll talk to you soon